why is seven out of ten a bad score I
hope you're having a good PACs are you
all having good PACs I don't know it
sounds like you are all right
I am Edmund Tran and I am the editor of
GameSpot calm and with me today I have a
bunch of journalists and writers and
presenters who I greatly admire and
respect as people and professionals to
my right over Lucy Jane Lucy O'Brien
sorry James my colleague Lucy O'Brien
the entertainment editor at IGN are no
writer of great views round of applause
for Lucy please I also have miss
Richardson who some of you may recognize
him the TVs
he's a presenter on a good game and I
show that famously rates games with
rubber chickens I believe previously oh
thank you so the rubber chickens were
not my idea I take no responsibility for
that no close finish please
I also I appreciate you pronouncing the
H at the end but it's it's just nick
hispanic but niches but niche is
acceptable because like [ __ ] yes yeah I
took a punch yep Dave Norma the editor
of Game Informer Australia one of the
most widely read print mags I'd say
probably in the world
and on the end we have James O'Connor
freelance journalist and critic who
tells me he has written up to a thousand
reviews for a variety of publications
including hyper PC power play edge red
ball whatever heaps of things everything
round of applause for James
now with a crowd this large I'm assuming
that there are going to be a lot of
questions but we'll save those to the
end about 20 minutes but do you think of
them and lobby two mics on either side
so once the time comes please do come up
to those mics for questions um so to
kick off we're going to talk about game
reviews in general how we think about
game reviews how our outlets doing game
reviews and the idea of sevens average
scores what is a good review what's a
bad review and so on and so forth but
the thing I'm most interested in with
this panel in particular is how
different games publications actually go
about reviewing games so what's your
scoring scale like when you review a
game how do you approach it and
basically what do you look for and how
do you write it and how do you come to
your final conclusion let's start with
you Lisa okay all right well okay so
I'll give you a little bit of a rundown
about how we do things at IGN basically
we have a score word attached to every
number so for us a seven is actually
good and a lot of the time when I'm
reviewing a game I sort of don't think
about the numbers so much as I think
about the score word so for us seven is
actually a good game it's a game that
has flaws and obviously in the review we
will outline those floors for you but
it's also a game that we enjoyed and we
would recommend you pick up if you're
interested in that genre or whatever so
you know seven unfortunately it's kind
of one of those like unfortunate little
little guys you know he's kind of had a
bad reputation um the scale of games
reviews seems to go sort of bad bad bad
bad seven pretty average eight yeah nine
good ten masterpiece yeah so you know
it's seven has unfortunately got this
reputation of being of being average
but at IGN a seven
is good god damn it yeah the salmon is a
good game I feel like most games like
thank you for that
let's go on to Dave about Game Informer
how do you review games okay so we like
IGN have a keyword attached to every
score and we're one of those seven is an
average publications sorry and I know
that that sounds weird but I think there
are very good reasons for that and part
of it is because you're ones twos and
threes and fours need to be reserved for
games that just don't work there is a a
technical component in this medium that
you don't get in cinema you never sit in
a theater and fail to see moving
pictures you never pick up a book and
one chapters in Portuguese like that
sort of stuff does happen.we games it
doesn't happen often but that's why five
is not quite average on our scale so um
so yeah average eight is very good nine
is superb and ten is outstanding and
just in terms of when we are writing
these reviews
the numbers come into it right at the
end I really think we all spend a whole
lot longer thinking about the words and
I know everyone else flips to the number
first but I think every single critic
that's ever reviewed a game would spend
90% of their time thinking about what
they're saying and the rest of the time
coming up with the score that's not that
we don't think about it but it's just
it's a little reductive just
distilling it into a ten-point scale I
actually I actually score a game based
off what I think of the first reveal
trailer and then I just I go into the
review just making the game fit the
score that I've already given sky it's
him yeah yeah that's how we're reviewing
bethesda games from now on - just based
on that's really interesting because
yeah when I typically write a review I
don't think about a score when games but
rice reviews we typically write the text
and we send that around to colleagues
you know writers to to give it a
look-see give it a QA and then they'll
tell me what they get out of that that
text so this feels like a seven this
definitely feels like a nine more like
so on and so James you've worked for so
many different outlets this is a much
variation to how different publications
approach reviews now for sure I think as
you've all sort of said scores are
largely codified they match up to
certain feelings and understandings of
there's no scientific basis of these
numbers so different publications
interpret these numbers slightly
differently and that can lead to some
interesting things that I have to think
about as a freelance when I'm running
for a lot of different publications one
of the one of the places I write for is
a kids magazine on the games editor of
mania magazine and I don't think I've
ever given a game below of four in pania
because of a game is worse than that and
I just don't review it and uh the only
times I've ever given it for is if a
game is really bad and I think kids
might want it and I feel like I need to
warn them not to buy it like that
journey book ride I came back in the day
my absolute favorite scoring system that
I have ever worked with is a website
called Zam that I started working for
this year but it's based out of the US
their review system at the end the
verdict is simply yes or no and I don't
tend to think of reviews as me telling
you whether you need to buy the game or
not because ultimately there are many
different factors some people buy the
game regardless of what you say economic
factors factor and time factors so I
tend to think
of a review of saying whether a game is
worth your time or not whether it's
worth looking into and finding out if
you're interested in it and just start
boiling it down to yes or no right at
the hint of review is actually a really
great way of coming off the fence I find
ok I remember I gave Mirror's Edge
catalyst a know earlier this year and it
was really refreshing needing to make
that decision because otherwise I think
I would have just given it like a 6
probably and sat on the fence so yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
variation in different scoring systems
like a game informer I write for them
that I tend to score maybe a little
higher in game in formula in another
publication just because they have a
very clear outline of what each score
means some others like the hyper
magazine back when they did reviews in
the magazine a much looser system it was
a little open to the interpretation of
the writer
I always felt in that one so yes for
sure there's big variations between
publications and as a freelancer I have
to think about that all the time every
day there's only a handful of reviews
that I've ever given never later
regretted the scores on I other people
have that do you have numbers that you
regret giving to go absolutely like
there's a game called resonance on the
on the PC it's like a point-and-click
adventure game and I gave it an 8 I
still wake up in the middle of the night
sometimes thank God I should have given
that 9 that game was really good
I get best you know 7 as an 8 out of 10
game
I gave home fronting 8 why I don't know
I honestly it's like it's something I
actually can't explain I mean I like to
I sort of I'd like to think of myself as
a good critic you know obviously that's
that's what I do for a living but for
some reason I temporarily lost my mind
tell me about how the ABC approaches
reviews with your game because do most
people might be under the impression
that most presenters like do what the
reviewing is that the case yeah it is so
like occasionally for giant games or
multiplayer games you will get everyone
involved but we're I mean we're in a bit
of a different position where
good game doesn't review everything
because we just don't have the the
screen time but also I mean people are
reading we're like people who read a
loser review and they'll be heaps of
people out there who are like this is
Lucy and I know her opinion and so like
I'm going to read this review with that
context but there's also a huge amount
of people probably more people who are
like this is what IGN thing so you're
under the banner of IGN with good game
because it's more personality driven
because you just see faces the reviews
are more just about what the person
thinks so play the game we hammer around
like notes turn that into a script and
it's super super personal and then you
read it out in front of everyone and
then we sort of talk over kind of the
same as the what you were talking about
where it's like we have people suggest
what they think this the star would be
the star rating except it's out of 5
which we hundred-percent need to get in
the 5 versus 10 battle because I think
the 10 correctly the like rating score
is kind of nuts and and led to the 7 and
[ __ ] 7 that then everything under a
5 like I don't know what the difference
between a 1 star and a 4 star game is
but yeah that's kind of how we do it I
think we also shot ourselves in the foot
25 years ago when we started scoring
things out of a hundred it creates this
false impression of science and
objectivity whereas five stars doesn't
have that corner station that's that's
you're talking about art and that's my
opinion
viewing out of a hundred is kind of fun
though because you've reached the number
of the annually how the hell did I come
to this number how did I decide 77 well
this game deserved may I'm gonna cut you
off there and we can save your questions
to the end Lucy does IGN still have a
point decimals we do we are a hundred
point scale
I've always wondered how you come up
with those bubbles this one points well
it's very unscientific let me tell you
that yeah I mean for me sometimes a game
like if it's a six but it has a couple
of really
ideas that I think are worth a little
extra more but it's not a seven so it's
an average game but it's not a good game
but it's not it's not a really bad every
game the world is on fire yeah it's a
pretty okay average game so um you know
God it's when I say it out loud I sort
of hate myself so I'm like the footnotes
like you go this is the the score is a
seven but if you go oh we've got an
extra point because really nice particle
effects in one thing it's very much a
sort of well it deserves a cut it
deserves a bone you know I do the point
thing is definitely a you know throwing
the game a little bone there a small one
again these are pretty codified like if
you give it a game at eight point nine
that's like a statement saying and then
beyond like the 9.0 any school beyond
that there's a fairly big difference
between like a nine point one and a nine
point five and the way there isn't
between a seven and a seven point four
or an eight point eight and a nine point
of view well yes so if you guys know
about this but I reviewed uncharted 4
for rgn and incorrectly do we do we do
preliminary scores basically based on
especially if the game has a preliminary
score like if we had to score it now
this is what we'd give it
so I played through the campaign and I
gave it an eight point eight and the
internet went after me with pitchforks I
got really drunk that night and then I
you know I play through the multiplayer
and I was like this is this is fun this
is worth point to more are you caved in
to the pressure oh shut up no I didn't
and this was homefront all over again I
know the vinyls go was a nine and people
were perfectly happy with that so it's
very it's extraordinary how much point
two I can make such a difference when
nobody was buying an eight point eight
game
let's talk about review regret have you
ever you will be touching an early a bit
you know when you play when you play a
game and you review it you want to get
it out to the people as soon as possible
you so people know about it but games
stay with you for a very long time if
you guys have a reviewed a game and then
you know a week later and month played a
thought the game deserve way more or
wait less even yeah yeah I mean III
think I am I think for me I gave my
review until dawn which is again some of
you may be familiar with it's a Sony
exclusive it's a horror game which is a
genre I'm very fond of and I think I
gave it a 7 or maybe a 7.5 and upon
reflection I actually think that it was
right it deserves higher than that like
III think that you know I'm not I'm not
it doesn't keep me awake at night but it
had such clever ideas and it really gave
you a sense of a real sense of choice
and consequence that I think we're
missing from a lot of you know dream but
you know like it was it was a successful
game and I think I underscored it just a
little
we're not even not even a sense of
choice in concert like actually like it
didn't make me feel as though oh you've
been funneled into this thing like I I
played that game and I managed to keep
everyone alive except right at the end
where I killed the chick from heroes no
I killed her that's not a spoiler like
you you might have been fine and that
was absolutely devastating yeah yeah and
she was this character she was she was
the best guy I mean it doesn't the eyes
are still terrifying but the rest of it
was pretty cool I I have one and it's I
don't regret the score but I got a few
things I said I reviewed the first
titanfall which I really liked and I
gave it a high score I gave it a 9.25
quite 2/5 9.25 I scientifically at 9.25
that's a fun system to work with it's a
great system but what I didn't realize
was as soon as I finished that game
literally a week later I just stopped
playing it I lost all interest and that
was the little
tail that just wasn't there and that's a
very hard thing to work out when you're
trying to review a game sometimes bright
at least this wasn't prior to release I
had a few days before we're going to
print while it was live so we could test
it on live servers which is also another
thing we should possibly talk about
because that's important as I was riding
that tech stomach I'm gonna play this
game all year I was convinced and then a
week later I was like not but do you
feel do you feel like your time do you
feel like you should have given a lower
score because you didn't stay with it
but the time you had with it was so fun
like you could give her a game that was
two hours long a nine yeah I mean that's
a great question but it's I guess my
point more is it's very hard for any
reviewer just to work out how long the
tale of this yeah especially in this day
and age where games often have massive
updates for example I know again I gave
League of Legends a six about ten years
ago it still preserves a 602 forever
there are so many instances where games
just get better with life oh the user
base is there and helps a game get
better and so on and so forth now in the
day in the age of the internet you get a
lot of feedback and we talked about this
with Lucy as well did you guys ever get
positive or memorable feedback from any
of your reviews well maybe we can start
with someone else David with print do
you ever get any letters to the editor
we do but if you're reading a print
magazine you are a classy individual we
just genuinely get a whole lot of lovely
you get a really nice feedback we have a
great community and I think part of that
is there's a filter they know that
they've betrayal isn't gonna get read by
anybody but me so it takes a lot of
personal Dave hey yeah we get that but
it takes a lot of effort to put pen and
paper like it really thoughtful concise
interesting letters that I end up
publishing in a letter section because
that's fantastic stuff so I guess I'm
kind of the only person here that
doesn't get the pitchforks on the
internet a whole lot which is great a
little bit
James to get pitch box I've done some
pitch box I feel like most of the most
of the positive feedback that I've
gotten from people has been for the most
negative reviews that I've written like
I wrote a review of beyond 2 souls for
us gamers I gave it a two point five out
of ten
they don't like that game people still
come up to me today and tell me how much
things with that review like I mean I
reviewed ee7 legends for Hyper magazine
and the verdict at the end was a turgid
tragic piece of [ __ ] people really liked
that they still put that back to me
occasionally when I say I like a game
people don't care I made a game people
are into that we we don't get that much
hey we get it I mean I guess we get
different kind of hey we get people who
hate us as people which kind of like I
don't really give a [ __ ] what you think
about what I think about a game but when
you tell me I'm a bad human being then
that actually hurts but I think it's
actually because again because it's so
personality driven people understand why
I might not like a game my budget
doesn't like a game why stiff does like
a game like the you go in going oh okay
I already know you're not gonna like
this so you pay you're probably not
gonna review it or if you don't like it
I can understand it if you do like it I
know exactly why that is so um they're
much more forgiving because it's kind of
like your friend doesn't like it as
opposed to just the stranger on the
internet like you just need to whack
your face up as the big picture on each
article
well maybe holding a puppy and then and
then it like how could you hate someone
with a pup a rescue that's that's a very
strong thread I think that's going
through what we're talking about here is
that reviews a definitely subjective
opinions of a certain individual and
mostly vitriol that we get a GameSpot
and I assume IGN as well is people
thinking that we've reviewed the game
incorrectly we haven't gone through it
scientifically or objectively enough but
that's certainly not the case as it
folks well one of my greatest examples
of crazy
commentator logic was actually was the
Uncharted 4 review hmm because I'd also
reviewed rise of the Tomb Raider which
is obviously a game
in a similar genre but the difference is
one has this this is according to the
comment section the difference is that
one had a female protagonist and one had
a male protagonist so I scored it raise
the Tomb Raider nine point three and I
scored uncharted for a nine and so the
content sections were telling me that
the reason I had scored and it was they
were like she doesn't even realize she
did it unconsciously was that I scored
and rises to read higher because Lara
Croft has a vagina and Nathan Drake has
a penis and seriously that was a really
like that was a that was one of the big
things I remember like one comment
saying that got tons of likes and you
know they were like oh because she's a
feminist and that's the reason why she
doesn't realize blah blah blah it's just
sort of like people think that I'm
insane I mean it's also incredibly
telling about those people's mental
state and how they view women that they
think a woman is poised worth zero point
three is that codified in the scale at
the point for a vagina bonus I think my
favorite criticism that Lucy has ever
gotten that I recall actually was on
your beyond two souls review you Lucy
maybe you told me somebody accused you
of not liking the game very much because
you were jealous of Ellen Page who isn't
she's great
now let's talk about just out jobs as a
concept like this day and age do people
really need reviewers with with
publishers coming out with their own
sort of sort of previews on games and
stuff and lots of like streamers and you
know YouTube people like playing games
online and having so many avenues to go
see games being played and you being
able to make your own judgment of it
are we still relevant no I like I think
a hundred percent but III for more
on the side of sort of streamers and
let's play I do way more of that than I
do actual reviewing but I I sanely value
reviews because I know that the [ __ ]
I talk about while I'm streaming a game
is nothing compared to like the the
analysis and critique that you put into
when you're actually reviewing something
and I think that I think that the space
for both things to exist that you need
you need a cultural language to frame
how you'd look at art I mean really how
you look at anything and that's that's
what reviews give you I don't know if
necessarily like actually I think scores
aren't important but I think being able
to develop a way to talk about video
games as an artform is really important
and and that comes out of not hey is it
fun but like why is it fun what is it
trying to do what is it what is it doing
that's different and that's what you get
from reviews that I think is most
important like just [ __ ] the score off
and just like leave the rest of the text
I think every critic doesn't want to
affect a game sales anything that's ever
been the point I think it is about
creating a more interesting just
discussion around a game I think that's
really and so the industry might ask
this question our reviews still relevant
and the answer almost certainly is less
so than before from their perspective
because there are far more voices I mean
consensus matters if everyone's saying
this is good then yes it will affect
sales inferences it's bad at will as
well the perhaps the weight of one
individual review matters far less but
that's a burden to be lifted from a
critic shoulders really none of us want
to feel like you know we got a studio
shut down and people got fired because
of that we just want to point out that
this is an interesting game and point
them towards the people that will enjoy
it or what really yeah I mean I think
it's still really important for
consumers to have a critical voice that
they can go to that they trust I think
you know it's it's someone on Twitter
said this and it's very true that it's
fast becoming the godwin of game of
games arguments around this but no man
sky is a very good example of a game
where I think it was very important to
have for consumers to read reviews first
because the finished product was
different to what the marketing was
promising us so yeah I mean I I will
always think and I personally go to
Rotten Tomatoes and metacritic whenever
i'm buying something or going to see a
film like i I want to know what I'm
giving my money towards you know so yeah
I mean I I agree that like it's all
expanding but I think as Nick said
there's definitely room for for both of
us I understand also why Studios
choosing to shut out you can shut us out
I mean mister is is a sort of good good
case in point recently I totally you
know I I don't I'm not happy with that
call but I completely understand why
Bethesda chose to make that decision but
yeah I will always stand by the
importance of of critical voices always
absolutely I'm not gonna argue with that
at all
I think the Davitt the DES de thing is
really just the formalizing of something
that a lot of people have been doing for
a long time anyway
spoken for ages and you know when you're
thinking about there's a whole lot of
money involved in these games from their
point of view why take the risk
you know why invites someone to come who
might not actually enjoy the game you
can see it from a business point of view
but I just I really would urge consumers
to wait for those reviews if if they're
late I would yeah yeah don't like
pre-ordering is a really flawed I don't
know if you guys agree with me but I I
don't think pre-ordering is I think you
should wait those extra weapon skins yes
sure it's the only possible way to
distribute and as with anything it's
important to get a variety of inputs a
variety of opinions of rarity of
perspectives on anything in life really
do do you think that with the Bethesda
model like if or if more companies jump
on the formalization of what they're
doing does it change the way in which
you will cover the games because I feel
like you're from if you can't review it
before it comes out then the longer goes
on then the less value
necessarily the score is but then I
think almost the more valuable the the
writing about the product is the the
critique and how it you know you can and
you can write about it after it's come
out like the effect that it has where it
sits in the current state of what games
are like is that is that something that
you could shift you're moving away from
necessarily reviews and more just like
analysis of something big sites when we
can't get a game review out day in day
you know that's something when you got a
lot traffic people always want to know
whether or not a game is good that said
you know it's important for reviews to
obviously play the entirety of a game
before giving an opinion I think I don't
think any publication would skimp on
that and you know some also some of the
best games writing usually comes out
does come out weeks after but reviews
yes reviews are always we we want to get
them out on time so I'm actually
reviewing just wanted to but yeah like
that's gonna be that's the first sort of
instance I think in my career at IGN
where I haven't had you know time really
so it's gonna be I'm gonna be playing it
from midnight right through the next day
and that's gonna you know it's it's
changing the process for sure yeah
because it's just the freelancer
lifestyle generally you get the game
that comes out right then you can't
sleep for a few days you since well the
reviews written and it definitely it
that it affects the quality of the
review because the whole point a game
former and I'm sure everywhere else he's
to play the game the way a consumer
would play it provided you have enough
time because if you're playing a game
for 12 hours it's no game is fun after
that long really you just you get
annoyed at the game and you can't hold
it against the games it is not the
game's fault it's this ridiculous
deadline you have so managing that's
tricky and this new policy is gonna be
you see how it plays out we might get
some people coming up to the microphones
for some questions so if you do have a
question please line up but as they do
that let's talk about us as consumers
how do you guys find out about things
you might want I understood in consuming
like games and stuff personally I just
read written views I love but good
written review and I love a good
analysis yeah I'm I'm still very
old-school nice I wonder if that's
because we are we grew up with games
magazines and and games writing you know
I absolutely appreciate a good streamer
and a fun YouTube video and a good
television show but uh yes I'm still
very much a written word person Nick I'm
a combo of everything like I just
consume everything and I don't care how
I get it as long as it's good so I
highly value written stuff I love
long-form writing but but I I watch
heaps of streamers
I watched lots of YouTube videos as long
as what they're doing is there it's a
first look at a game or it's like an
analysis or something I'm not just
watching like sick head shots in
[ __ ] shooter fall so call of
shooting which came out on Friday so I
read I don't think I've ever watched his
live stream to be perfectly honest I
know yours I don't know I tend to I take
a look over Metacritic and I'd I don't
know everyone has sort of critics that
they look up to attend to particularly
respect the opinion of I think I read a
lot of Eurogamer that's that's my
favorite website I think because their
opinions has happened to line up with
mine very often they gave titanfall to
an essential that is an amazing games
okay should have talked about total two
more in this panel intro and by
titanfall 2 so I have someone to play
with online it would mean a lot to me
the end the voices that I like the most
you say that you really like you're a
gamer I'm like I'm the same way i I
actually like the ones who are really
opinionated and have a really strong
voice in
one direction it doesn't need to be
necessarily like a voice that I agree
with but where I go oh I can feel that
whatever you're talking about you're
really passionate about the thing you're
talking about you're not just doing it
because you have you got even they're
thinking you have to do it it's actually
like no all you're writing is about like
PC games that are under 300 megabytes
that run on a MacBook Air like that's
your whole website name like that's
awesome because you're gonna be the most
informed person about that thing I'm
just one more before we go to questions
do you guys feel the need to see a game
in action before you actually pick it up
I say no no no no if I knew the concept
um if that's enough if I know it has a
cool hook or something the reputation of
the developer is well yeah totally I've
been wined by thousand dollars worth of
Blizzard products without like seeing a
frame of what's going on yeah okay we're
gonna go left right left right so up to
the left mic on okay we got a cold mic
up front we've got a cold might know
talking to the mic please
hmm in a dream world in my personal
dream world which also features Ellen
Page I read um I would love to do away
with with numbers and just have the word
I think right now numbers are too
important for us to do away with but the
nitpicking that happens and the grief we
get over numbers is just so tiring and I
think that with a school word you can do
this you can do exactly the same job
except you're not gonna be under that
kind of scrutiny of you know the
numerical point and as I said you know
the point - for example I agree with all
of that but I think the one downside is
consistency and archive it's it's cool
to be able to go and see what Game
Informer said about the first game 20
years ago using the same scale so all of
all of a sudden we change the scale this
long history of reviewing games becomes
a little bit less relevant and yeah
personally I would love to not have
numbers but these are outlets that are
all bigger than Lucy and bigger than me
and younger than it's like it's just a
longer history yeah it's like the idea
of doing something where you add like a
play this if you'd like like like
comparing it not in a better than kind
of way but going like this will appeal
to like XY and Z tendencies we actually
used to do that away with it yeah do you
know why that got I actually don't know
yeah it was a just it was kind of
annoying something we used to do often
it takes where you'd be like you know I
don't like shooters but I tried BioShock
Infinite and this is what I thought of
it but that became far too much work I
mean got a lot of crap for it thank you
a question
yeah it's just they don't own the giant
companies thanks me question yet on that
like you've got your gamer which has the
recommended essential and the Boyd and
you've got Kotaku who has no score like
what's your thoughts of that and is
there like a conscious decision you
didn't have someone who didn't actually
like a site which doesn't actually give
scores on the panel um like you've got
your gamer with the recommended central
avoid and kotaku doesn't actually have
any scores and also corner follow up
with a conscientious decision not to
have someone on the panel use um site
doesn't actually not close guards like
okay why did we not bring in the enemy
was the basically we scores I think like
um I've done like I said why right for
Sam it's a yes or a No
which is not a scoring system so that's
that's enjoyable
I remember the the one of the earliest
sort of writing things I did was a a
zine called a pixel hunt and we worked
at a system where we were detach a
certain wood to the end of every review
instead of having a number and I really
enjoyed that it was a me was bad and
then okay and then different degrees of
good was uh that actually worked really
well but uh I guess we just we don't
really have anyone in Australia doing
anything like that who is doing it on a
big level at least like uh my first
writing gig was for a street press and
we didn't we didn't put numbers on
anything but also nobody read us yeah I
mean maybe if you put numbers on and the
thing
obviously you're a gamer doesn't really
exist in Australia
Kotaku does in mark and mark and Alex
good friends of ours but they don't
typically write reviews unfortunately
it's been really cool like talking to
you guys and hearing about how you
review game reviews really cool
interesting you were saying before about
hype and the expectations of a game
before gets released and then you know
what happens after a game you know is
released and I think you know we've seen
this a lot recently with games like in a
no man's sky marriage catalyst
Pokemon go so I just really want to hear
how does the hype of a game kind of go
into the review and you know how does it
affect your perception of a game when
you're playing it and you know do you
have any ideas and how we can kind of
help fix these like crazy polarizing
expectations that have happened a lot
recently with um crazy hype trains
that's a great question yeah does anyone
have a great answer
that's a critic it's um I thought I
don't get hyped that much these days
because I'm just being unloaded with so
many games that are at a certain point
it becomes a road I don't get excited
about things the way I used to which I'm
lady towards a happy point here just
like getting are you smiling so you
don't cry James is dead inside that's
part of the job like I feel like hype is
something that happens on a consumer
level people get very excited we get
excited about things but it's not quite
the same because we know once the game
comes out we're gonna have to review it
and there's gonna be hard work and I can
get excited about you know the prospect
of writing about something but I don't
necessarily get really amped up about
playing a game the way I used to
I think hypes like a self-fulfilling
prophecy because you go like it does
happen at the consumer level and so if
people are excited about something then
outlets will write about it because it's
like that's the thing that everyone is
talking about and then that makes the
consumer go everyone's talking about
this let's talk about it more but I
think
I think the biggest thing with hype is
you just like people just need to
realize that marketing is there to lie
to you the whole time and that's not a
bad thing like that's just the job the
job is to make the thing that the
selling you look as cool as possible and
so they're going to show you the best
possible versions of it they're going to
like throw it in your face in the
coolest possible way and you need to
just go okay like you need to watch it
and go okay cool that's like a really
beautiful lie and if 30 percent of that
is there then this might not call but I
think that it's really easy and I do it
as well but it's super easy to just go
no this is exactly what it's gonna be
because what they made this thing why
would they possibly like not not why
would they possibly lie to me and then
and then that's where expectations just
sort of blow out proportion we had a
panel on game trailers here yesterday
and the beauties of trailers like that
from plastic wax and some of the
publishers who commissioned them all
agree that you know everyone should be
viewing these trailers as advertisements
for what they are in terms of um sort of
cutting down hype games but until very
recently you have separate preview and
review teams so once you want to go out
and review a preview the games before
released and the reviews team that would
specifically early review the retail
copy that no longer exists unfortunately
but when we do review again we make sure
to have the package that goes out to the
people yeah I'd say the hype actually
affects our preview coverage more than
our review coverage like very separate
from a review you just lock yourself in
a room and you don't read anything but
when you're previewing you do have two
responsibilities and one is to try to
analyze this game as objectively and
critically as possible but also keep in
mind that it's not finished yet and it
could really be broken and you do have
to occasionally give the developer the
benefit of the doubt I mean I did a
preview of battlefield 4 six months
before it was about to get released and
it kept crashing like constantly kept
crashing but because it's dice you you
do give them the benefit of doubt and
they have six months to finish this
thing but we all know about that launch
and it didn't work for almost a year at
yes also I think it's much more relevant
when it comes to to previews and reviews
to be honest and that's actually there
not to happen it but that's the
interesting thing about the Bethesda
move is that they're they're stopping
the possible you know getting a 8.9
review
coming out of the day the game launches
but what they they're still gonna get is
all the coverage in the preview and
that's actually the most important thing
for them because it's the thing that
gets everyone talking about it so like I
mean obviously you guys can't stop
reviewer Hill previewing Bethesda stuff
or maybe you can and that would be sick
but it's like yeah but that's like the
that's this sort of I think that's a the
weird balance right now and so yeah it's
about just not buying into the [ __ ]
that they're trying to spin you
everyone's lying to you Brian every run
even packs is a lie thanks a question it
was the right hi yeah so very
interesting point you man of about the
updates so we've noticed that some games
and some triplet companies have been do
this for they release their game and
then two or three weeks later they
introduced some pay2win mechanics
whether they be significant or
insignificant have you ever thought
about doing something where when
something like that happens has it ever
been tempting to kind of go back and be
like you know I'm updating my review I
know that hasn't happened yet but have
you ever considered that well we we
revised reviews but we do it much later
on like we wouldn't do it if it was just
a three week something like a patch that
came three weeks in but we do like I
mean for example look at destiny you
know it's like I actually did give it a
seven but yes we we do have a policy
where we will go back if the game has
dramatically changed I mean
unfortunately that doesn't affect what
is sitting on Metacritic and never will
and we do not change like we'll do
another review but we won't change that
original score I know polygon very
frequently edits the reviews post to
account for those patch changes and tons
of games but we we tend to happen we try
to extend the review in progress because
final score it does matter yeah that's
right I mean if if it if it is like a
patch that comes in day one obviously we
will not post the final score until that
patches we're kind of limited because
when it's in print it's in print and you
just can't change that that's the review
forever but we do talk about things
afterwards we have some weird things we
don't give scores to mmo's because of
that like GameInformer still has not
given World of Warcraft a score 7-7
philia 7 so yeah it's just about being
aware
I remember reading a Nintendo 64
magazine back in the long-past days of
my youth and every every issue they
would pick out three games that they had
reviewed previously and just completely
changed the score it was a weird thing
like I remember like if a sequel to a
game came out they might read you the
original said nothing should now take up
30% that must have been very confusing
for readers yeah probably
different no different field back then
they just a quick question do you guys
think that critics need to be good at
games oh it's need to be good gainers
they need to be competent I think it
depends on the game to some extent it
absolutely depends on the game I mean I
for one could not play I don't see I
can't even say the genre cuz I'm sorry
like I'm submitting race racing games
racing car games you have a license in
real life I do but I haven't driven for
six years I would be the last person on
the planet to review a racing game
because I'm I I have no interest in them
a and B I'm terrible at them so yes you
need to be competent at what you're
reviewing absolutely do you need to be
like top ranking in the Worlds gamer
hardcore person not because there is
this funny conspiracy at the moment that
polygon isn't any good at games if you
see
yeah like cuz I'm [ __ ] terrible at
video games and like I'm I will beat all
of you in half stone like I will take on
every single person here and I'll knock
you down but I I think it's it's about
but what I'm really good at is I'm
really good at analyzing things I'm
really good at providing critique I'm
good at finding and yeah and throwing
people against the wall which you would
so many like um super game that was a
now boy and then that was also someone
who just got close I think it was the
key to uh sitting here um the I don't
but I don't think you necessarily need
to be amazing you just need to be like
appropriately informed about the thing
that that you're reviewing can I also
just quickly say in polygons defense I
have nothing to do with polygons i I
don't actually really actively know
anyone who works with polygons they're
all based in the States but that doom
video that could have been made the
thing is with these with item with teens
like IGN and GameSpot and polygon and
kotaku is we have huge teams so the
person that made that doom video who was
playing probably wasn't an editor just
probably some like video you get up at
midnight to play yeah hey kid hey kid if
you do this I think it was actually off
at games but then he denied it or he did
a bit but also like there's all sorts of
other things where you go you could be
like you could be someone who plays
shooters only on PC and then you get
sent a ps4 version of a game and so then
you need to use a controller and like I
am way better with the mouse and
keyboard than I am with the controller
and then you give me that and it's it
wrecks you and then but also like like
you're not there to see the headshot
you're there to see the whole game and
go I can do way better it's far more
important to me that you know how to use
a semicolon than that you've got a
really good kill death ratio they
separate independent clauses or they can
be used to separate long complicated
items in a list that's the only two
years
that's where I work with is going but
you know with reviewing it's obviously
you're not gonna be so about it again
that you can't finish it because then
there's no point in writing the review
really is it next question hi you
mentioned earlier about how people get
really angry at review scores
particularly they focus on the number
ignore all the words have you ever
considered that when writing a review
and being tempted or even have adjusted
them because you were afraid about the
backlash you would get like I would have
thought that the IGN review for Doom a
seven which is heresy by the way but
that kind of score there was a lot of
backlash for that obviously no he wasn't
he was a freelancer that we brought into
right there no it was not me okay good I
would have given I would have personally
given it a title
I love to yeah I can't let that affect
your score you just can't and if you do
you're just not doing your job properly
began and what and why would you want it
to as well like why would you why would
you want someone to go oh I think the
game's better than it is like it's their
opinion so like their opinion either
means something to you or doesn't like
if you're just looking for validation of
what you already think about something
then there's no point in retest and also
the other thing is you know I feel like
I've really received pretty much the
worst that the Internet has to throw at
me you know what I mainly I have I have
copped a lot of [ __ ] since my my debut
at IGN in 2012 where I wrote a piece
called
ten movies that you love and why they're
not that great not a fantastic debut
probably not the smartest idea it was
number one do you remember I think it
wasn't it wasn't a miracle but I did put
Forrest Gump in there and I swear to God
I got so much [ __ ]
but yeah you know like I you know I've
I've I've copped a lot of crap so now
I'm just like after us with the
Uncharted thing I was just like I was I
found it funny I didn't even you know
and and I suppose that comes from being
somewhat seasoned I can imagine that if
you were just starting out and and it
might be a different story but yeah for
me personally and I imagine for all of
you guys too because we've been doing it
for so long you just you never think
about about the backlash you don't take
that into account you just won't do it
as a job like if you actually did that
you ago you're just looking for approval
the whole time I don't think you'd
particularly last in the industry
the important thing is follow your heart
thank you Thanks question when it comes
to games especially now with multi
platforms and I can night comes his mind
especially when you have such great
reviews on two systems on consoles then
you come to a PC game where some
reviewers were going we're not going to
review it to the patch comes out
should they be reviewing at that point
because at the time that's the way the
game's released other games always
improve the patches that point your
review welcome that was an interesting
one because they actually pulled it from
sale entirely until I got a patch and I
think most PC places do review the the
release version and see what it's like
at that point and then sort of update
with like a news stories going forward
about what happens from there don't they
if you're being asked to hand over your
money at a particular point and that's
the point that we can put a score on it
I think we we do separate PC reviews if
the PC version is dramatically different
if it's more or less the same then we
will include a paragraph later but if
the PC game is fundamentally broken like
in that instance then we will write a
separate review for the PC version
that's much the same for us we also make
it clear which platform we reviewed on
the little disclaimer at the bottom this
review applies only to the PlayStation
version not the PC for something is as
Extreme as Arkham Knight like as as a
consumer would you want it like that
game straight up didn't work for a huge
amount time to the point you know where
they pulled it would you want a review
of that game because what you're
actually reviewing is like the game does
not work . it's a zero because the game
does not work like you cannot launch it
you can't buy it it's a zero is that is
that valuable to you since you already
know that because you would have
followed the news or is it more valuable
to wait until the game does work and
then you can look at it as the actual
game was supposed to be like you're not
you're not forgiving them for it but
you're going okay well like I just I
can't review this until it starts
working I didn't pre-order it I saw the
battery so I didn't buy it from other
customers yeah yeah something like that
yeah it was a few days down that's a
long time for a game to be especially
how some of them get knocked down for
being fakes nowadays it's just ashes
cricket 13 did any of you guys see or
hear about that that was remarkable they
pulled it off sustain a day afterwards
and refunded everybody because it just
didn't work I think we made some comedy
videos he did anything it ever came back
did it never came back it doesn't exist
anymore I've got probably a type of one
more quick question fortunately I sorry
my name is you in love with me you all a
few weeks ago James you wrote an article
on the political significance of Forza
horizon 3 in my opinion attracted a lot
of negative feedback on on Twitter and I
know at least you got involved and I
wondered if you guys could weigh in on
I guess political discussion in video
game writing and even including reviews
as well and what you think there is a
place in that how about that should be
handled just to be clear that was not a
review I know you didn't say just
because I feel like I need to say that
every time I talk about this article now
was that intended as a review really
liked the game write a review of AG 24/7
liked a lot playing whole discussion is
I mean we can't escape our personal
politics whether whether we all agree
with each other you know everyone has
these views everyone has feelings and we
can't get away from them they influence
the way that we interpret
art in all forms out and meteor I think
and when I wrote that article that was
my way of working
feelings that the game brought up for me
because of my personal politics was not
intended as a as a comment on the
quality of the game or about how the
game worked within my understanding of
the world which i think is a perfectly
valid thing to do I think um you know
absolutely reviews are always going to
be subjective but I think I love those
post review analysis for me I think it's
really important that we can write about
games through a political lens I think
if you don't it's just so boring I mean
and there are a lot of there are a lot
of people out there who don't want us to
write about games through a political
lens which is insane because games are
political I mean God look at Mafia 3 for
God's sakes you know that was it's all
about racism like it just tell me about
the frame rate we just ignored that you
know and Iran as well and we want them
to be taken seriously like movies like
music like books
I feel political politics influences who
we are I think one of the problem is the
death of nuance with social media it's
very very easy to think that grand theft
auto might have a problem with the way
it represents ruin women also that it's
an awesome game like these things are
not mutually exclusive it's like there's
a huge echo chamber where they think
everything is a zero-sum game it has to
be one or the other I can't be both at
the same time and I think it's actually
irresponsible to not call out a game
because it is a piece of art and also if
they are hugely influential you do not
call out the the [ __ ] that they like
portray like Grand Theft Auto the fact
that it still has such hate for women
and minorities is that is despicable but
it's still a great game and if you don't
talk about that stuff then it's never
actually going to change like it's you
have to talk about that but people just
think because you're saying that you're
you're both going Grand Theft Auto sucks
and you're a bad person for playing it
and that's and that's just not the case
game to go ahead we all love games and
they
deserve to be talked about in a variety
of ways and never pre-order anything
babies in James IV never Tran enjoy your
packs everyone